dado un rectángulo con largo cuadrada
más 6 a 27 y ancho a cuadrada menos 9
escribe la razón entre el ancho y el
largo como una expresión racional
simplificada muy bien nos piden la razón
entre el ancho y el largo lo voy a
escribir por acá ancho ancho / largo
esto de aquí sería esa razón entre el
largo muy bien y luego queremos
simplificar esa expresión pero aquí nos
dan el largo y el ancho así que déjame
empezar copiando los de este lado
tenemos que poner el ancho que esa
cuadrada menos 9
a cuadrada menos 99 y eso queremos
dividirlo entre el largo que es cuadrada
más 6 a cuadrada más 6 a menos 27 menos
27 muy bien estoy aquí sería la razón
pero nos piden escribirlo como una razón
simplificada y para simplificar esta
expresión lo que tenemos que hacer es
factorizar el numerador y el denominador
si logramos factorizar los si tienen
términos en común entonces podemos
cancelar los y encontrar algo un poco
más simple vamos a hacer eso déjame
empezar factor izando el numerador que
es a cuadrada menos 9 estoy aquí es un 9
a cuadrada menos 9 esto es una expresión
de la forma cuadrada menos b cuadrada
porque 9 estrés al cuadrado entonces la
podemos factorizar como a más raíz de 9
x menos raíz de 9 nos quedaría
voy a ponerlo así a más raíz de 9 o sea
3 x a menos raíz de 9 o sea a menos 3
aquí simplemente estoy utilizando la
fórmula de diferencia de cuadrados si
recuerdas cualquier expresión que se vea
así como a cuadrada menos b cuadrada se
puede factorizar como a más b
por a - ve si no recuerdas por qué se da
esta igualdad puedes multiplicar al lado
derecho y ver qué queda el lado
izquierdo bueno vamos a seguir con este
problema eso lo queremos dividir entre
esta expresión y para factorizar a
cuadrada más 6 a 27 necesito encontrar
dos números que multiplicados me den
menos 27 y sumados meses de me den 6 y
esos números a ver me parece que son 9 y
menos 3 a ver voy a escribir la
factorización y ahorita verificamos que
funcione entonces eso
a más 9 x a menos 3 vamos a verificar a
por aysa cuadrada a x menos 3 es menos 3
a 9 con nada es 99 menos 9 a menos 36 a
ajá y menos 3 por 9 es 27 entonces en
efecto esto de aquí es la factorización
y observa que aquí ya tenemos este
factor y este factor en común en el
numerador y el denominador así que
podemos cancelarlo
pero antes antes de que perdamos
información déjame escribir algo
importante necesitamos ver cuando el
denominador se hace cero para saber
cuando esta expresión no está definida y
cuando el denominador se hace cero bueno
pues se hace cero cuando es igual a
menos nueve o bien cuando a es igual a
tres entonces voy a ponerle aquí que 'ya
tiene que ser distinto distinto de menos
de tres de tres y esto es importante
porque habita que simplifiquemos que
cancelemos estos términos puede que esta
información se pierda sino la sino la
pues conservamos si no la ponemos aquí
al lado entonces ahora sí déjame
simplificar voy a cancelar a menos tres
a menos tres y esto me queda igual a
igual a además tres armas 3 dividido
entre a más 9 a las 9 y es muy
importante escribir que a es distinto de
menos 9 y de 3 a es distinto de menos 9
y de 3 observa que aquí ya no tenemos el
a menos 3 entonces de aquí ya no podemos
ver que a es distinto de menos 3 y por
lo tanto debemos de ponerlo aquí al lado
para que realmente estas dos expresiones
sean equivalentes bueno entonces la
razón entre el ancho y el largo como una
expresión racional simplificada es a más
3 entre a más 9